global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from London
[Music]
Save the King
there is no mistaking this moment King
Charles III crowned in a Sumptuous
seamless ceremony in The Soaring Nave of
Westminster Abbey a fusion of medieval
and modern I come not to be served but
to serve Queen Camilla crowned two in
the same Abbey where coronations have
taken place since 1066.
[Music]
range of more than 2 000 guests from
celebrities to presidents to volunteers
and Community workers Canada's prime
minister was there too and carrying the
flag astronaut Jeremy Hansen
there was Fanfare from trumpets
and A procession back to the Palace in
the gold State coach
only then from the balcony could the
king and queen fully see the sea of
people who had stood for hours in the
rain to witness this moment in history
[Applause]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the long Arc of history of the monarchy
the medieval Traditions the swords the
crowns the robes the Oaths they were all
on full display it may seem a bit out of
place in 2023 but it's a kind of
spectacular event the British Royals are
known for our Crystal commencing was out
in the crowds and the rain soaking up
the atmosphere Crystal yeah it pretty
much rain the entire day Donna but it
really didn't change anyone's
expectations of the day everyone just
seemed to be out there hoping to make
some memories
uh William Prince of Wales pledged my
loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear unto you as your lead man of
life and limb so help me God
a pledge to his King a kiss for his
father and a thank you whispered in
return the coronation of the king May
focus on one family but it was a bonding
moment for many yeah family moment
history in the making life history I'd
like for one day for them to say yeah I
was at the coronation with my dad back
in whenever the service made history in
a number of ways God of compassion and
mercy never before have we heard the
Sovereign pray out loud and never before
have non-Christian leaders taken part
some moments were still too sacred to
share the Archbishop of Canterbury
Anointed The King on his head chest and
hands away from peering eyes but there
was no hiding the family drama his
brother prince Andrew did not play any
official role but attended wearing the
order of the Garter the oldest and most
senior order of chivalry in the UK and
Prince Harry walked into Westminster
Abbey alone meanwhile the woman he
called a villain in his book is now
Queen
Diane brayerton got emotional out along
the mouth talking about the coronation
recalling her grandfather's role in the
last king's coronation he was selected
as a color Sergeant to march in the
king's coronation that would be King
George V in 1911 and here is his uh this
is his invitation colors color Staff
Sergeant John Mill 36 peel regiment I'm
getting tearful now I'm just thinking
that's my grandfather right there so
here I am 112 years later you know not
marching in it but being here for the
coronation and it just means the world
to me
thank you
Canadians have a long history in
coronations that tradition was on
display again as five RCMP Riders were
featured prominently on horses given to
the Royals by Canada while the pageantry
was breathtaking it was the crowning of
the king that captivated this crowd at
an overflow screening location and
brought them to their feet
[Applause]
while the Kings wore an oath to uphold
the laws of the land but tonight it's
the actions of police that are in
question earlier in the day a number of
individuals were arrested including the
head of the anti-monarchy organization
Republic 51 others were also taken into
custody police officers saying that
preventing A disruption was more
important than an individual's right to
protest I spoke with graham Smith
earlier in the week and he said police
were well aware of the group's plans to
demonstrate at Trafalgar Square and
didn't raise any concerns and Donna
tonight it's unclear if any of those
individuals are actually going to be
formally charged lots of questions about
that Crystal good man saying thank you
astronaut Jeremy Hansen was asked to
lead the Canadian procession into the
Abbey today carrying the Canadian flag
he came up here to the rooftop right
after the ceremony and told me he'd
never been to Westminster Abbey before
it's a bit surreal you know there's a
lot of uh it's a lot of history and you
just feel that it's it's I I would find
it hard to find or find the words to
describe it but it's one of those things
where you're sitting in the moment
you're like wow you're just impressed
and there aren't really words to
describe that emotion inside but I I was
sitting like right there in the king and
the queen were just on the other side of
the wall I was sat behind and it felt
felt Monumental for me yeah really
something and and carrying the flag
right through between the Thrones and
past all of that and the Altar and the
the Last Supper on the wall I mean that
was quite an honor just to walk through
there
the former National chief of the
assembly First Nations is here in London
too Perry belgaard didn't go to the
coronation but he does have immense
respect for the king you'll hear why a
little later but first we turn to
Alberta where wildfires are continuing
to force thousands of people from their
homes more than 24 thousand people
people have had to evacuate across that
Province five thousand others have been
told to leave at a moment's notice there
are more than a hundred active wildfires
in Alberta right now 32 are out of
control 45 of them started since 11 A.M
yesterday one of the hardest hit
communities is Fox Lake where more than
3 500 people have been forced to flee
their homes our need to garcha is in
high level Alberta where evacuees are
taking shelter nitu is there any word on
people might be when they might be able
to return home
yeah Donna at this point it sounds like
it could be weeks before residents can
return to the community of Fox Lake but
there is some good news tonight Little
Red River Cree Nation confirms the few
people who had been reported missing
have been accounted for and are safe
helicopter and ground crews are focusing
their efforts on preventing the
extremely active Wildfire near Fox Lake
from spreading any further into the
community
[Music]
Little Red River Cree Nation says more
than 40 homes have already been
destroyed with little chance of the more
than 3 500 evacuees returning home
anytime soon based on the work entails
it might be maybe a couple weeks and but
we do have rapid
deployment Water Systems in place
west of Edmonton dozens of new and
growing wildfires have forced several
thousand people to evacuate including
all of Drayton Valley on Thursday a town
of about 7 000 people
on Friday large swaths of Yellowhead
County and the entire town of Edson
which has a population of about 8 000
people were forced to flee and thousands
more from the town of Fox Creek were
handed evacuation orders on Saturday
Hart was pounding for sure when we were
driving out so but I think thank God
that we uh we got we got home like my
career and I got home safe to our
families it's crazy
I mean who would have ever thought that
you know most of Northern Alberta was
going to be in this situation provincial
officials say the situation is evolving
rapidly it was so much kindling all it
takes is a few Sparks to ignite some
truly frightening wildfires these
conditions have resulted in the
unprecedented situation our province is
facing today back in Fox Lake which is
only accessible by barge the chief
highlighted the need for provincial
Highway upgrades I think if we had the
the appropriate infrastructure in in
Northern Alberta especially in around in
and coming into our communities I think
we would have been a little faster
getting people out with no relief from
Mother Nature the hot dry conditions
across Alberta have prompted a
province-wide fire ban
here in high level which is about two
hours from Fox Lake you can see smoke
and Haze blanketing the region and while
it's a little calmer here in the area
around the Wildfire winds have been
consistent and strong and fire officials
say that remains one of the biggest
challenges in the fire fight tonight
Donna
okay Anita Garcia in high level Alberta
thank you
wildfires are also threatening
communities in neighboring BC in the
village of McBride which declared a
state of emergency residents face
immediate evacuation orders because of
the out of control tier Lake Fire
officials say high winds have made
things worse there too and further north
residents in the red Creek and lower
cache areas are also under evacuation
orders as more than 1500 hectare fire
grows
a look back at a life in Waiting coming
up we revisit the king's decades-long
Journey to the throne
[Music]
this was a view from the sky as
Britain's famous red arrows flew over
Buckingham Palace earlier today quite a
sight we're back from London in a moment
foreign
coronation King Charles was both the
oldest and the longest serving Heir
Apparent in British history he'd held
the title of Prince of Wales since 1958
and inherited the title of Duke of
Edinburgh when his father Prince Philip
died in 2021. Eric Sorensen looks back
at the king's long road to the throne
Elizabeth proudly presented Prince
Charlie to the world he was born to be
king unlike his mother who became The
Heir Apparent only when her uncle
abdicated
crowd surge forward to get closer views
of their own first family by the time of
Elizabeth's coronation four-year-old
Charles was already being groomed for
the throne the Prince Charles proudly
presenting his many school friends
Charles was the first heir to the
British crown to go to school his mother
had been tutored privately he was the
first to earn a college degree an
accomplished Horseman a naval officer an
early advocate for the environment but
always he was preparing to be king which
imposed stiff constraints on a reserved
young man the level of Freedom he
experienced was significantly less that
the kind of education he was expected to
receive the the Social Circles he could
have the expectations upon Him meant his
early romance with Camilla Parker Bowles
was deemed unsuitable she was among
other things considered a commoner the
royal family was however quite enamored
of Lady Diana Spencer the daughter of an
Earl even though she was a teenager
almost 13 years younger than Charles I'm
amazed that she's been enough to take me
on
and I suppose in love
their wedding was the social event of
the century
foreign
but there was unhappiness Charles kept
up a hidden friendship with Camilla and
in the new era of intrusive mass media
Charles and Diana's troubles were
exposed for all to see the Princess of
Wales suspected that her husband never
really renounced his attachment to his
great friend the marriage broke up and
when Diana died in a car accident public
esteem for Charles and the royal family
sunk to a new low
and so began the laborious task of
rehabilitating his relationship with the
public and laying the groundwork for his
future
Charles made it clear that Camilla would
be by his side she doesn't bring the
sparkle that Diana did but does provide
loving and trusted support she had made
Charles extremely happy her main aim is
to help him to support him and she's
been loyal to him for so long Charles
Devotion to duty is a quality he shared
with his late mother but his education
and passion for issues like the
environment have prepared him with a
more outspoken view of the world as I've
tried to indicate but quite some time
the climate crisis really is a genuine
emergency and tackling it is utterly
essential Charles must also tackle new
family Dynamics primarily with his boys
William the Constitutional heir to the
throne and Harry now very much an
outsider
still his larger role will be on the
world stage starting with the
Commonwealth and its Colonial history
Canada's attachment to the monarchy will
certainly be tested he faces unique
challenges as king of Canada the nature
of indigenous reconciliation a nation of
many people many languages Charles is
really confronted with the reality of
showing people why the monarchy is
relevant some view Charles rain as a
placeholder between Elizabeth and
William both more popular than he but
for now it is his dynasty and his
kingdom an apprentice and a prince for
more than 70 years Charles III is as
prepared to be king as any Monarch in
history
Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
I'm insight into how the
how the crown indigenous relations
[Music]
the South African singer pretty yende
who became the first African to sing
solo at a British coronation we're back
from London in a moment
[Music]
for many indigenous people in Canada
trying to deepen ties with a monarchy is
complicated given the history of
colonialism but some leaders like Perry
belgaard believe King Charles plays a
vital role in progress for
reconciliation the former National chief
of the Assembly of First Nations was
here in London he didn't go to the
coronation he's an honorary president of
the Royal Canadian Geographic Society
though and he's worked with the King on
climate initiatives I spoke with him
earlier
so I read what you wrote recently I saw
in the Regina Leader Post Yeah the op-ed
you believe that King Charles should be
commended why do you feel that way
well for a number of things I think he's
way ahead of his time
and what I mean by that he's been
talking about protecting the land and
water for over 50 plus years and a lot
of people thought he was crazy 40 50
years ago talking to plants and figuring
out how everything works together and I
say he's way ahead of us and he's a
leader ahead of his time because of that
he's recently created a couple of two
very key initiatives one's called the
Terra Carta and the other one is a
sustainable Market initiative the SMI
and you're involved with the sustainable
marketing and why is that what is it
that Drew you to that well his
invitation his invitation to come and
help because he gets it that indigenous
knowledge and Elders traditional
knowledge and getting our world view
inside the private sector and inside the
public sector and in balancing uh you
know development finding that that
really really good balance between the
environment the economy he gets that and
he asks for help on that four years ago
2019 uh he invited my wife and I to
Clarence House his personal residence
now he's King uh he has the power to
convene
and he has the power to bring people
together what is the sustainable markets
initiative what's its aim its aim is to
basically get corporations and companies
and nation states and everybody else to
put the planet first nature first in
their business planning models you can
quantify keeping the force that as
opposed to cutting it down because it
captures carbon you know you can
quantify having clean streams and lakes
and Waters and and clean oceans and so
the whole goal of the sustainable marks
initiative is to have sustainable
development globally which really means
a sustainable future for our children
and grandchildren and those yet on board
which is in keeping with indigenous
values that's why we have a strong
connection right and you first met him
in 2001 yes what do you what did you
make of the man
well again we thought he was uh a very
gifted individual uh very down to earth
very warm very caring very interested in
learning from our elders he was really
humbled when we blanketed him with a
star blanket and he was very humbled and
touched when elder late Elder Gordon
Oaks from nikonid First Nation bestowed
the name upon him give him a Cree name
gave him a queen name his scalpiu kanawa
pamago and Cree and in English basically
what it means is
the sun watches over him in a good way
the sun protects him and watches over
him in a good way and do you have hope
of with this king and the future of
indigenous relations with people in
Canada of course there's no question
he's already made his trip to Canada in
May when he was Prince of Wales and he
made a very strong powerful statement up
in the Northwest Territories about
reconciliation and about listening to
indigenous peoples and learning to their
from their stories learning from the
residential school history learning from
the Indian acting position learning from
that genocide and the colonization and
all of that and he also made strong
statements about the United Nations
Declaration on the rights of indigenous
peoples and that's really a road map for
reconciliation not only in Canada but
throughout the world if nation states
give it legal effect and in Canada
they've done that so I have great hope
this to me this Monarch this new newly
minted or newly crowned King gets it he
understands it and there's no question
there's uh
great hope for the future thank you so
much for speaking with us thank you for
the opportunity
[Music]
the challenges facing King Charles
ah
the 62-gun salute at the Tower of London
marked the exact moment the Saint
Edwards Crown was placed on the king's
head at the coronation we're back from
London in a moment
[Music]
it's Now official Charles is king and
his Reign begins in Earnest his mother
though is a hard act to follow and his
biggest challenge is remaining relevant
at a time when interest in the monarchy
especially among young people is waning
wading to his subjects from the balcony
of the palace where he was born the new
King's whole life has been forged in a
crucible he could never Escape his
Destiny I here present unto you King
Charles
your undoubted king so what kind of King
will he be those who've watched him
closely believe he'll be a kind of
gentle activist using the Monarch's
power to convene that's the sort of
power that monarchs have always had to
get people together and and leave them
to sort it out but you can still get
Authority yeah it's okay everyone look
you know here's a big issue I can't
officially take a position on this but I
you know I've got so-and-so here and so
and so here maybe you could sort of come
to an agreement his challenges a
disgraced brother an estranged son and
polls that show most young people are
either ambivalent about the monarchy or
actively dislike it I come not to be
served but to serve his coronation oath
is to serve his friends say the king
does not want to be revered receive this
all he knows to many the monarchy is
archaic I want to see an Australian as
Australia's head of state Australia's
prime minister hasn't set a time frame
but does want to cut ties with the
monarchy that doesn't mean that you can
not have respect for the institution
which is a system of government that we
have Barbados has dropped the Sovereign
as head of state six other Caribbean
Nations have signaled still follow suit
even in Britain the anti-monarchist
movement is vocal
some of them arrested today during the
coronation procession whole point of
today from the Republican side was this
Minister here just to show that when the
cameras pad around that they wouldn't
see just rows and rows but don't worry
play this and to show the world that
we're not a nation monitors
as Shakespeare wrote heavy is the head
that wears the crown that is global
national for this Saturday I am Donna
Friesen there were so many moments from
the coronation we want to leave you with
a few more including some behind the
scenes moments from inside Buckingham
Palace after the ceremony for now thanks
for watching and good night from London
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign